[Musique]
c'est ça la vidéo regardez moi cette
vidéo avec plus de 1,6 nom de toi elle
tend démis l'épaule quand tu l'avais vue
ouais et là là parce que les gens ne
connaissent pas son histoire mais là
aussi ça me met un peu plus les poils
parce que parce que voilà lll dans une
association parce qu'elle a une maladie
le problème allait chanter cette chanson
pour elle c'est pas pareil les mots sont
différents pour les beaux yeux d'emma et
figure toi khaimah et bal avec nous ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la bei
dgo
chéri d'amour étudié qu'un peu en plus
on peut penser qu'on s'est vus
dernièrement parce que on a passé un
petit peu les vacances ensemble ma
chérie
c'était bien oui c'était pas trop chiant
non ça va j'avais un rêve c'était tu
voulais ressentais quand même avec sopra
juste un petit couplet un refrain avec
le rouge avec emma ma chérie tu nous
fais tes partante ou pas oui et je vais
vous raconter une anecdote sur la tête
de ma mère dans la voiture l'été cet été
et un moment je ne savais pas que
j'allais pas de musique dans la voiture
et un moment je t'en es en fait elle
commence à chanter dans la voiture elle
commence à hurler chute avec un copain
on est vers les larmes aux yeux de rire
pascal est parti en freestyle à un
moment dans la voiture elle a hurlé tu
te rappelles ou pas je vous a fait qu'il
fait froid
oui
[Applaudissements]
attention la mare
montceau pas
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
là
il y est
toujours selon m
hugon pour remplir les garder
le sourire
et proche à point et pas des moindres
comment
un fait semblant on élude et quand je
chante je danse mais quand ça réglages
et mon absence est infondée
devenir de ce fait dormir donc je vaux
o o
de ma vie laval
à vauban turku le monde avec des
épreuves
roy
de là
ces mêmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la plus sûre et la noire savamment db ça
va mon coeur est content d'être là
vraiment donné
[Applaudissements]